alastair campbell is with us now hello
to you mr campbell you were very
forthright in your views yesterday and
still the prime minister is in power
well he's in the building behind you i
don't think we can call it in power we
don't have a functioning government we
don't have a functional prime minister
and this is what happens when you put
somebody like him in charge boris
johnson is somebody who thinks the rules
don't apply to him
he's operated by that his entire
existence and what you're seeing here
is a single human being testing massive
constitutional principles he talks about
this mandate that he got from the
british people
he got the votes from the people of
uxbridge he was the leader of the
conservative party who won
the election he therefore became and
remainders as prime minister you can
only govern with continuing consent of
the people you can only govern with the
support of parliament which is losing
and you can only govern with the support
of your cabinet which is losing as well
and so he is now seeking yet again to
say that the normal rules of life and
the politics do not apply to him and
he's damaging the country in a way that
i worry is irreparable you've seen there
with brandon lewis brandon lewis is gone
i've been you know agitating against
brandon knows for some time over the
northern ireland protocol i think he
should have gone some time ago because
breaking international law on such a
vital matter of public interest is
frankly grossly irresponsible but how
can you now have a functional government
when that one of the biggest challenges
this government faces who's he going to
put into northern ireland now who can he
actually ask to take this on so i just
think that the whole thing is what
happens when you get one narcissist i
think probably sociopathic because this
is now utter bunker mentality without
any sense of responsibility to the wider
world and these cabinet ministers fair
play some of them have stepped up
they've all got to step up and they've
all got to say i'm sorry your time's up
out you go off you go and we'll have to
try and sort this mess out after you've
gone
they tried that yesterday it didn't seem
to work
well they tried it okay but you know
that they're doing it in their own
different ways michael gove seems went
and said to him listen what are your
times up and what was johnson's response
it was to you know
dig down deeper into the bunker take out
the revolver and shoot michael gove
there will be others in there i don't
know if it's true that pretty patel has
told him that he has to go i don't know
i only realize you do or what people are
telling you there's larry the cat on you
on the doorstep larry the cat right now
would be a better prime minister than
boris johnson anybody on the planet
would be a better prime minister than
borrowers johnson why because he's not
capable of governing this is what he
lives for getting into massive scrapes
and then trying to get out of them
um tomorrow just reminds me of an
article that boris johnson wrote when
gordon bryan was holed up in number 10
seemingly clinging on for dear life it
is you know perhaps something that
desperate prime ministers do
well i do think that was a very
different situation gordon brown fought
the election against david cameron the
outcome was unclear yes david cameron
got the biggest number of seats but he
didn't get a majority and gordon i think
behaved incredible responsibility
responsibly and i actually was in the
room with gordon brown when he was on
the phone to nick clegg and i can
remember word for word the words gordon
said to nick clay nick we cannot keep
the queen hanging around for ages you
have to make your mind up and nick lake
made his mind up to go with david
cameron so i think that is completely
different gordon brown was actually
trying to make sure that the
constitutional principles were upheld
what's happening with this guy is he's
sitting there thinking okay i've got
away with lying to the queen about
prorogation of parliament i wonder if i
can get away with doing it again now the
idea of this guy now leading the
conservative party in the general
election is frankly ridiculous he's
becoming utterly ridiculous i think
loathing of him is turning to absolute
disgust but the only thing i care about
in this is the damage that's been doing
to the country i always get i talked to
you yesterday i was getting hundreds
hundreds of bids from news news
organizations around the world this
story is playing out right around the
world we are a global joke and until
this guy goes the world will continue to
laugh at us and that will continue to
damage us
we are you know we rather call ourselves
the mother of all parliaments and are a
little bit superior when it comes to
other parliaments around the world how
come
somebody who it would appear that almost
all of the politicians that he
represents want him out can still stay
in power what does that say about our
political system
it says that our political system
depends entirely on the honourability
of the people we elect to positions of
high office and this is what happens
when you elect somebody utterly
dishonorable when margaret thatcher was
confronted by political reality of her
cabinet colleagues saying to her sorry
margaret you've been a marvelous prime
minister for us you've been a great
leader for us but time's up she went
when theresa may was confronted by the
reality of what happened to her she went
people were tony blair when tony blair
after 10 years in office but took a
decision eventually that it was time to
move on gordon brown was taking over he
went there are certain pressures in
politics and sometimes you have to lead
on them other times you have to respond
on them and i do think out of this there
has got to be a fundamental review both
of our political system and indeed of
our media culture because i think the
media and particularly the right wing
press has a massive responsibility for
getting this guy into office in the
first place for brexit which is going to
be his only legacy and that is the
tragedy of this whole thing a liar and a
crook was put into downing street to
quotes and gets brexit done we're going
to get rid of johnson but brexit we're
going to have to live with for some time
so that this is what's happened okay we
put a liar and a crook into a position
where in our constitution it depends on
people who get elected to parliament
being honorable he's utterly
dishonorable he's a disgrace to politics
he's a disgrace to parliament and to
this country and the sooner he's out of
that building preferably in the back of
a black mariah the better
well that's not going to happen as we
both know but it's a good sign bite um
is it him though or is it the people
that are around him you know are the
people around him strong enough to you
know there's no hezer in there at the
moment so there's nobody of his stature
there's no elder statesman to go in and
say
time's up off you go
well that is a problem but that's what
happens when this goes back to who and
what he is as a leader he is
deliberately surrounded himself with
weak people he's appointed the p there
are people in that cabinet who wouldn't
get a job you know as driving a van i
mean they're just not very good people
they're not very good at what they do
can you imagine nadine doris in any
other cabinet in history can you imagine
suela bravoman is now talking about
putting herself forward for the
leadership i mean these are fourth-rate
people so there may be people in there
and it's and it's not the job people are
saying why can't the civil servants get
him out it's not their job they have to
try to make things work as best they can
i also i did an interview on irish radio
yesterday and stanley johnson johnson's
father was on still defending him still
saying he's honest still saying he's
honorable still saying he's the right
person for the job i mean for heaven's
sake or his family not going to step up
is his brother not or his brother's not
going to step up is his sister not going
to step up this guy is doing massive
damage to one of the most important
countries in the world anybody who has
access to him should be getting the
message in for heaven's sake just you
know do the decent thing do the
honorable thing resign and let the
country try to rebuild from the absolute
chaos that you've created